even if you work nine to five if you
work eight hours a day
and you sleep eight hours a day that
means work is
50 of every hour of your whole day
for 40 years of your life
like why the [ __ ] are you doing
something you hate
make less money buy less fancy [ __ ] and
be happy
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
huge day at adhd because i got my friend
gary vaynerchuk
in the studio dude thank you so much for
for coming on i really better
mother nature yeah we were talking
before the mics cut on
and uh literally if it wasn't for a
blizzard we wouldn't be doing this right
now that's right supposed to be in
chicago today
uh in l.a tomorrow real quick before i
go to phoenix but
a lot of snow so my admins adjusted
they're like we're sending you to la
first thing in the morning i'm like cool
and i remembered that you reached down
and i was like i really wanted to
support you
i appreciate that um and i was like it
slid into your dm
got tight and slid literally yeah no we
literally did everything via via
instagram yeah which is you know it's so
incredible in the digital age but one
thing about you man
is you you don't only talk
you don't really talk you walk it you
know what i mean you you give away
things for free
you you build genuine connections with
people and you're a man of your word and
i think like integrity
is something that you don't come across
very often out here
you know what's crazy is it's mainly
because i'm so flattered the fact that i
know
that having me as a guest gives you
leverage
for the guests you get after this it
makes me feel
nice and like it's like such a crazy
feeling
it's like and and i think that all of us
want to put people on especially if we
genuinely have a vibe towards them
and i think that i loved being the whiz
kid in the wine world
and the tech i loved being that whiz kid
as a 12 year old baseball card dealer
but it's now you know just turned 43 as
now i'm going into
that next chapter i remember being 25
27 and worrying that like oh [ __ ] one
day i won't be the whiz kid and am i
gonna be sad
but i'm super fired up to be yoda right
like
yeah like you know i haven't seen creed
two yet right but rocky's in the corner
and i'm sure at some point rocky was
like [ __ ] when i'm not gonna be in the
ring is gonna be as cool
but now he's getting his high from
training up the next generation and i
think
you know i'm not 70 yet but no question
because everybody's in it so much
younger these days
i probably got to feel og a little bit
earlier
than i anticipated um but yeah at the
end of the day
like also i got to tell you having a
good memory helps
like literally getting a text from my
admins and being like we're sending you
to la
realizing i have nothing booked because
my day was planned in chicago
plenty of things to do but being able to
be like oh [ __ ]
he might be around and just do like
having a good memory
has been a sneaky like like i never talk
about this but like
so much of what i pull off is based on
having a great memory
you know one thing that i look to you
for uh in a big part of my journey and
my career my life is self-awareness
and and one thing i want to say to you
is self-awareness is scary
as [ __ ] um if you're good at judging
yourself
i think self-awareness if you're capable
of
accepting yourself for who you are is
actually
the brightest light of it all i love
being self-aware i suck at a lot of
things
i just don't think about them like i
can't read for [ __ ]
i interrupt people when i interview them
24 7. everybody's super pissed on the
internet about that
not good because i already know what the
person's saying i can't help it i'm
sorry
there's plenty of things that i'm not
good at i love self-awareness i like
it's kept me so happy
like you know i'm not upset of myself
that i'm selfish in certain areas
that's human i think that we just don't
love each other
ourselves enough i i think we
i don't know who's perfection i'm trying
to live up to
like if i like silly things like people
get on me for biting my nails
gives a [ __ ] like people are just
critiquing themselves all day long
you like reading the comments love you
do it on every video every post
all day how do you how do you deal with
the negativity someone's talking about
biting your nails
empathetic empathy
somebody just watched 49 seconds of me
spitting some pontification on instagram
and they've decided to make a judgment
on me and i respect that i put myself
out there
they don't know everything about me so
when they
drag me down be like this guy's a
[ __ ] idiot who's full of [ __ ] or what
the [ __ ] or
i'm like that makes sense they saw me in
explore feature they're like who's this
dick face
they watch it they don't like it and
they decide i'm [ __ ] and they're not in
a good place so they have to
drag down i deploy empathy first
sucks to be i would never do that as a
happy person to anybody else so hey i'm
already
feel bad yeah and b who the [ __ ] am i
they only got 49 seconds and in 49
seconds at a time
i could suck [ __ ] in perpetuity
you know like at 49 seconds at a time
i could be all-time terrible especially
me that gets hot and competitive and
like
you know like this is how i am when the
lights come on so
i deal with the negativity with empathy
to the person that's leaving the comment
a for the fact that i feel bad because
they're in a bad place that they decided
to put more hate into the system
and b like they shouldn't do seven
hours of research of my career or who i
am as a human being
i would be upset if you thought i was a
dick
because you've had enough interactions
at this point to have a read
yeah but like rick in arkansas
or new york who saw me in explore or who
saw
by the way and i i have a lot of empathy
because i also have fans
and followers and people that consume my
content that really give me love
and you know the natural reaction when
somebody's posting like this guy's a
[ __ ] genius
you know 30 of people like [ __ ] that guy
before they even watched anything yeah
i get that so i mean i hated tiger woods
and kobe and shaq in their prime
they weren't my guy so i i have empathy
i i put myself out there and if you're
putting yourself out there you have to
deal with the ramifications of the
reality of the system
so i respect the system i respect the
market if you don't know who i am and
you think i'm
the biggest piece of [ __ ] i'm great if
you know who i am
and you think that i'm dead and that's
how i live my life
speaking of empathy you know the reason
why we started talking last week
is you launched empathy wines yes
congratulations thank you
uh you know my mom's not gonna listen to
this podcast so it's safe to say that i
ordered her a bunch of
a bunch of wine thank you for christmas
uh why
why empathy wine why now john troutman
and nate schroeder uh two guys that have
worked for me for a decade
graduated up the wine library and vayner
media system
and we're getting to that age where they
were like hey what's next for me
our capabilities to produce content and
marketing to sell a product
off the back of the k-swiss stuff was
obvious to me that it was
very high i miss wine i was going to say
is this nostalgic it's
almost like a nostalgic for you don't
ever step i also knew i could do it
i knew that i could produce the best 40
wine in the world and sell it for 20
bucks like people are gonna
[ __ ] when they taste it i can't wait to
get mine yeah literally yeah like the
amount of
empathy rose that is going to be on
instagram this summer
and spring like through i i can't wait
from from
ghana do you know you need to get some
rose too my friend shamiq moore he's the
voice of uh of miles martin the new
spider-man movie is coming out
anytime we go to dinner he like we can
go have lunch
at 12 00. i got you i got it so
there was a lot of factors i was ready
i'm a timing guy i was ready to start
a project that was direct to consumer
on the back of internet marketing 2019
in a category that i was deeply
knowledgeable in
um timing and it's a subscription
service
you can buy three six or 12 bottles
of each of the red the white and the
rose uh and
it's a subscription service most people
don't want to think about wine people
hate going to bevmo and total wine and
costco and wine library like
it you have to go and so once i convince
everybody that i'm producing the best 20
bottle of wine i think it's going to be
a beast another thing i want to bring up
is trash talk
yes probably one of my fav it is
definitely my favorite new gary vee
uh thing to watch it's so entertaining
you're literally going to people's
garage sales you're buying things and
flipping them on ebay why
what made you want to start doing this
it's become
very obvious to me that excuses are my
poison
and i want to eliminate them at all
costs i talk a lot about hustle and hard
work and people are kind of pushing back
on me a little bit right now
and it's been interesting i'm like man i
haven't done a good enough job
clarifying that when i talk about work
ethic i'm trying to speak to people who
are unhappy or complaining
not happy with your job don't watch
netflix work after hours
save money quit i'm not trying to get
people into depression
or burnout i'm trying to address
unhappiness
um one of the things i saw a lot in my
comments because i read them all
was well i have no money i'm like [ __ ] i
lived my whole life with no money but i
figured it out
i would just buy [ __ ] i would buy garage
sale [ __ ] and it just got me going going
i love it it's like a hobby of mine to
go garage start doing that with clothes
i did
i used to do that with clothes dude you
met guys especially like a stylish kid
like you like if you have flavor
if you're listening right now and you
don't have money but you're cool or fl
you got flavor you got swag you got
style if you just spend your life
in goodwill and in thrift stores yeah
and buy [ __ ] that
you think is fresh and then wear it and
take a [ __ ] selfie and put it on ebay
for three times the price
or like i see every day the amount of
people that buy three dollar t-shirts
and sell them for 35 bucks
on ebay and etsy and [ __ ] facebook
marketplace is enormous
there's no excuse in america to say you
have no money
even if you're in the deepest poorest
places because if you can
literally get a dollar you can buy your
first t-shirt at goodwill
and get it up for 15 bucks on facebook
because you know what's funny
what's funny is everybody's got a
smartphone
like you go into the poorest places in
america and everybody's got a smartphone
which means you have the internet i mean
listen the homeless
you've got people all over on home
homeless smartphones i get emails every
day
i'm homeless i watch you on youtube
you know so i don't know i really and
listen of course there's one percent
that don't and i
that's what's always fascinating to me
the one percent that populates like what
about my aunt i'm like cool i get it
but i'm trying to address 99.9 of people
and the garage sale thing's been huge by
the way
huge i have tens of thousands of tweets
emails dms messages from people over the
last hundred days
who are completely inspired by the show
and are making significant money
and significant comes in all forms do
you know what it's like
to make an extra 200 bucks a month when
you're not doing well financially
huge huge like it [ __ ] matters
it's also fun for fifty percent of
people
like that's the when i watch the videos
and i'm watching you like go and you're
getting
you're picking up these stuffed animals
do you know what this is gonna sell for
40 bucks 50 bucks and seven bucks i get
pumped like
buying something for a quarter selling
it for 11 on ebay
with the fees with all the [ __ ] that
everybody makes fun of me in the
comments for what about the gas all that
like
i'm still like i made six bucks i bought
it for a quarter i sold it for 11.
net six bucks or i could be jerking off
on my couch right now watching [ __ ]
netflix
like if you complain and you're unhappy
i will spend my career suffocating the
living [ __ ] out of you
to prove that is basically and by the
way out of gratitude and guilt
i've come to realize this i'm so
grateful for my dna my parenting my
circumstance of growing up with nothing
and i feel a level of guilt i was so
gifted a mother
that put me in a position to succeed i
know that everybody has that
so i'm almost trying to play my parents
role for everybody that watches my
content
if you don't have that person in your
life let me be that shield
let me populate you up you're either a
person that goes into comments to drag
people down
or you're a person that puts out content
to put people up
i'm so proud to be the latter how do you
balance all of this man the shoes
the wine you know the content constantly
i mean your podcast your youtube channel
your instagram all of your socials
lack of obsession of perfection
i got it yeah i mean because so many
times you know i don't post something
or i i i delete the video or i say i'll
wait till i get the next the next better
photo
look i'm going through it right now it's
very clear to me that instagram's going
through its
like decline of organic reach
everybody's feeling it
and like even i'm like [ __ ] but like
like i'm pushing through and like
yeah lack of perfection i'm just i just
think doing 97 things at an eight
is better than doing one thing out of
ten
mainly because the math works out one
thing out of ten is ten
ninety eight at eight is eight hundred
you know like you know
how do you decide what to hop on as well
because i noticed you're you're first on
everything man
i read comments so then what happens
with the app
you remember that app that came out i
feel like last year uh
not strava it was another one oh vero
vero there we go
i feel you know i saw everything for for
two weeks and then nothing
that's where i'm really good i'm really
good at being patient everybody wants to
jump on like
peach is the next thing vero's the next
thing like everybody's like the next
thing the next thing i'm not obsessed
with the next thing i'm obsessed with
the right thing and doing it the best in
the right thing
yeah man i pay attention look i'm i'm a
creature of the culture
of the attention of everything i'm
watching i just watch
i'm v you know this is the funniest
thing about me i talk so much i
interrupt so much
but i listen man how am i [ __ ] first
on everything because i listen
i listen with my eyes right i remember
this very clearly three years ago i'm
just going through the airports i'm like
why are young women wearing
jeans with tears in them again like they
did in the 90s
right yeah i'm watching i'm watching
like
i'm watching like it didn't take me too
long to figure out like kids were
wearing champion hoodies or
fila's back or like i'm watching i'm
watching
uh gary yes i want to say thank you so
much man thank you brother um you know
you constantly inspire me
you're you know genuine so what's this
podcast going to be about
it's about anything and literally
everything you know it's me going
through my phone book it's me going
through my instagram dms uh and me
having all my friends and
and cool people in the world on to chat
about literally anything and everything
i love that yeah listen i'm gonna drop
one little thing that i've been thinking
a lot about over thanksgiving
it was and we talked about it just now
this is a game of selfish versus
selfless
if you ask me why so much good is
happening for me
is i get high on giving to others
it's like this perpetual machine i love
admiration admiration is
only earned nobody sees you the first
time and admires you
and so there's so many people that are
trying to build personal brands
trying to like get on you have to be
obsessed with every time you post
are you bringing value to everybody or
are you trying to get something from
them
you're giving or taking are you giving
or taking and
everyone's taking it's about how many
likes and followers you get
that is disproportionately a take game
that's it that's why so many of you are
struggling to pop
every post is will this get me do you
know how many
attractive women get frustrated after
three posts
and then decide to show flesh again
because the only kpi is likes
and will say to my face like i want to
build a fashion brand for women
and so i'm like take half the likes and
make content for women
not for pervy dudes
and they struggle with that and i and
that's why i want to talk about this for
the last sentence which is like
are you happy about your 40 000 likes
that mean nothing or do you want the 13
000 likes that are actually
predicated on your ambition oh wait you
want 40 000 likes because you
care about what other people think when
they see how many likes you got
like we are getting we are so deep
into a math game do you know how many
people would [ __ ] their pants if
tomorrow instagram decided to stop
showing likes and follows
oh it would be the it would be over
it would be the best thing for the
humans
yeah well i mean kanye a bunch of people
went on uh they went online telling
for twitter their kanye was like remove
the like in the retweet uh
you know the the numbers
yeah i just i i think if i think there
should be like
it'd be really cool if people could live
one month without seeing the metrics
they'd be
stunned by how much that would impact
what they put out
and that's what's worked for me like
i wa i'm interested in your admiration
what i love about when i sign sneakers
or when i'm in the airport
is the amount of people in the last six
months that say to me
i never fan out about anybody but i
needed to come and take a selfie
i brought your book when we first met uh
on my beach show
i was too nervous to have you sign it i
was like i never do this
and i'll tell you why it's so much more
fun
to be followed because someone admires
that you brought them value than the
fact that you can drop
55 in a basketball game or the fact that
you're a size zero
with a pretty face that's just the truth
i was wondering why it was happening it
was happening a lot like really famous
people like
freaking out or like you could just tell
when like somebody was in the scene all
the time
it was just like it was happening right
and i was like
right because i'm getting admiration
and that is something everyone should
try to
do and i think the reason is if you make
admiration the north star you will
produce
dramatically better content
you're not gonna try for a hack the
reason i was never in an engagement
group
is i don't need the [ __ ] metrics i
need admiration that doesn't come with
fake [ __ ] followers
yeah fake followers can't stop you in
the [ __ ] hallway to say that you
changed their life fake followers aren't
gonna ask you for a picture
they're just not gonna say that you
changed their life the reason i do
garage sale videos
is because people will stop me at the
airport and say that 900 bucks they made
during this holiday season that allowed
them to buy
a gift for their daughter because they
[ __ ] sold [ __ ] that was in their
closet
matter to their lives
not because i wore a cut off t-shirt
in a very attractive way seriously
why do you think celebrities are losing
what value are they bringing
you can't be an a-list hollywood
celebrity anymore and be cool
like angelo julie is not [ __ ] winning
brad pitt's era is over
because they bring nothing to the table
at least an a-list instagram celebrity
once in a blue moon may like
your comment there's at least a prayer
of an engagement those [ __ ] need to
learn too
by the way quickest hack i'm gonna leave
you with this if you're [ __ ]
trying to build a big audience and you
are not replying
to the couple of people that give a [ __ ]
about you right now you're a [ __ ]
idiot that's how i build myself
twitter 2007 to 11 i reply to everybody
you're telling me you want a million
people to [ __ ] with you
but you don't have the seven minutes to
say thank you to the 13 comments you got
you're [ __ ] selfish dick
it's a selfless versus selfish game 99
of people are selfish which is why 99 of
people will never build an audience
simple we're going to end it right there
gary vaynerchuk
thank you brother i love you buddy thank
you so much